Stewart: Well when you came along with
the Mars Trilogy, there were a couple things
that were unique at the time. One was
Mars was not hip then. It's insanely hip now.
And you were writing a pretty
leftist economic model onto basically
how the geo-engineering or the terraforming
of Mars would play out. Is that an accurate--
KSR: Yeah yeah, that's right. Stewart: And uh in your
mind were you doing that because that's how you
could realistically imagine Mars
actually being terraformed or this was
at last a platform to play out
some of your leftist fantasies?
KSR: Well maybe more the latter. When I was
writing the Mars books it was the Viking
data. The Viking data came in in '76. And
they gave us a Mars that was a
million times more detailed than what we
had before that. Mariner and Viking. It took
a while to assimilate, for science fiction
writers. And to say, well what have we got here?
And then it was Sagan and his crowd that said:
if you were interested in terraforming and
wanted a planet to do it, then Mars is as good as
it gets. You will never find a place that
is more close to being terraformable.
And they began to model it. So i was
the lucky recipient of that when i began to
write novels. And I saw that Mars
would be a great place to backpack and it resembled the High Sierra
which it didn't. But in Green Mars and Blue Mars
it does. So...
Stewart: It's Nevada that it resembles, right?
KSR: Yeah it goes like from the Ruby range in Nevada
to the Sierra to the Coastal range over the
trilogy. Um, it was something I wanted to do.
And then the leftist ideas was just my
my hippie California, Gary Snyder
New Age, Buddhist, you know, you know the
drill here I am!
Stewart: Gary was a red diaper baby.
He grew up with it. Did you?
KSR: No no
(haha). I grew up in Orange County to a...
a blue diaper baby. Whatever, it was not a
political household. It was a technical
and a pseudo apolitical household.
Stewart: Pseudo apolitical household?
KSR: Well, I think that the American
technical class would say (it happens too
often) that well, I'm just into technical
stuff. I transcend politics. Or politics
is the grubby stuff and Science is the
clean stuff, and they try to make an
artificial distinction between the two.
Stewart: So are you basically turning against that?
Did somebody get to you with a more
interesting and persuasive frame?
KSR: It was a
combination of Snyder, Fredric Jameson,
Ursula Le Guin, and the
science fiction community itself. I was
very lucky in my teachers: all three of
those were teachers of mine at different
times in life. Jameson was my thesis advisor
and he told me to write about Philip K
Dick, the greatest living American writer,
at which my jaw dropped. I had only read
Galactic Pot-Healer, and I was looking at
this professor thinking you've gotta be
kidding me. But i went ahead and i read
Phil Dick on Fred Jameson's behalf. And then
Gary was teaching poetry at Davis when i
was there. And so I took classes from him
and Ursula came down to UCSD and taught
science fiction writing at UCSD
so, I'm thinking:
just do what they tell you. And have fun.